stop the show Gang get an important
announcement the boys are doing a live
stream New Year's Day come hang out with
the squad down here with Toadies we're
gonna have some special guests might be
an appearance from Patty and Denise you
don't know what's gonna happen it's
gonna be a good time get a hair and a
dog in you kick off 2023 right and that
ain't it you bozos we got a third show
at the Gramercy theater shout out to the
army of garbage baby we're on sale now
our third show it's going to be February
3rd that's a Friday night get your
tickies now New York City Army of
garbage let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
group to be classy or if they're just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement uh-huh she's already
looking for resale yikes on that third
Gramercy show she's cop in Texas she's
competition scalping out there hey she's
she's gonna be wet in her beak any way
she can I feel Sierra walking around
23rd Street who needs two yeah she's
gonna be selling bootleg merch and [ __ ]
are you trash selling my underwear
I got a pair of his socks my co-host is
coming at you from across the table this
is a family episode he is the CEO of are
you garbage he is an international
businessman the brains behind the
operation put the whole thing together
but always makes time for friends and
fans
not up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rape you subscribe
on iTunes full video of album on YouTube
as you know those numbers are up uh and
then obviously the greatest goddamn
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage yeah you
sign up over there you get a [ __ ] ton of
content and that's legally binding you
get [ __ ] done legally binding [ __ ] ton
you get bonus episodes ayg you can get
episodes of hard feelings you get
[ __ ] uh the new travel Vlog we're
doing wheels up shout outs up we're
taking new guy Luke over to goddamn road
with us to shoot to shoot a little Vlog
style behind the scenes type stuff good
thing he eats like a bird huh yeah a
couple of chicken fingers for three days
he's all right let's give him a honey
packet he's good uh and then obviously
uh we are doing a live stream on January
1st baby a little bit of hair and a dog
a little bit of Hangover show start the
new year right new year off right with
the boys daddy yo it's gonna be fun
you're gonna get to see the moms a
little bit we're gonna to be going and
interviewing our moms uh my mom already
asked if she can have a glass of wine
before she does it so who knows what's
gonna happen I'm sure P Mayo is going to
be cranking Bernie's left and right it's
gonna be a scene oh man we're gonna have
some friends stop and buy it's gonna be
a good [ __ ] time game I'll have a
glass of white wine with uh with nisi
over there we all can I start doing
Shooters have a couple of nutty Irishmen
going around tell you to go ahead and
check the car
that's my mother God damn it send you
straight to reform school Punk how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones and twos
crosses the t's and dots the eyes give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen what up dudes hey if anybody
out there knows how to run a live stream
[Laughter]
guys in typical ayg fashion we're
figuring some stuff out yeah
it's gonna be good baby it's going alive
it is what it is you get what you get
all right I hooked up my VCR I think I
could probably help you out a little bit
I know the red the red the red thing and
the other one the white one never went
to anything yeah I don't know what that
was all about it'll be in HD so you can
see our cold sweat oh man
boys we got the oh he's gonna be
freaking out the whole time no you're
gonna be illusional I tell you I've
turned the corner I've let go I put my
my faith in uh in your gentleman's hands
I'll wait till you just [ __ ] up yeah
that's your biggest thing the second one
thing goes a degree off a [ __ ] plan I
told you you stinking piece of [ __ ]
every one of them tickets for that third
show at the gramer she better be sold
out otherwise I'm losing it let's go you
know what let me know that you let go
what's that the drawstring on your pants
and the and that bottom button you
couldn't do on your shirt we had to
dress you like a goddamn Mr Potato Head
before we started here I got it in the
air up the side of my head
anywho gang we're here for a family
episode we're circling the wagons it's
just the boys we're gonna be answering
some of your questions as we do we
always do I got something I want to get
into here what are you pulling out there
oh [ __ ] let's go boy Whoa
look at that get the [ __ ] out of here
doggy a hundred thousand Subs over there
on a YouTube as you know baby those
numbers are true to roof no presented to
are you garbage uh for passing 100 000
subscribers shout out to [ __ ] YouTube
baby let me see it
that's the fake one the real ones at the
house like the Mona Lisa damn that's
nice yeah I had it for like four days
you know how hard that was not to
[ __ ] tell anybody that's metal look
at that ladies and gentlemen thank you
thank you so much shout out to the bozo
shout out to the home and we started at
zero baby I'm gonna [ __ ] cry dude
that's I that's so [ __ ] cool dude
look at that huh do I have anything to
get it started Read It and Weep fatty
we're doing it [ __ ] and gang will be
auctioning this off
third show interesting trades accepted
where do we put this up after the show
somewhere yeah yeah there you go set
that right there you get right away
I think they send you another one I
don't think so it's kind of tough to get
that one really be honest with you
checking the Bots can you pass that here
I need to take a picture and send some
texts to my mom
you dumb [ __ ] I know you know what this
means but I'm awesome
[Laughter]
good stuff yeah it's good yeah yeah it's
wild crazy wild thank you that was the
longest I've ever kept a secret that's
crazy and I almost said it 15 times
today I would have never been able to do
pictures of it and had it loaded in the
group chat that I didn't send wow yeah I
like the I'm like what are you doing man
just do it on the show it'll be a bell
man I can't even keep a candy bar in my
pocket a secret that's crazy is that in
your book bag you took that down here on
a train looking to get robbed took the
train what are you talking about I got a
plaque from YouTube I ain't taking a
goddamn Train That's all pewter whatever
that is silver yeah damn that's all
right yeah it's all right baby beautiful
thanks shout out to the [ __ ] Army of
garbage baby coming out in [ __ ] full
force yeah the past [ __ ] the past two
weeks man we [ __ ] love you Daddy-o uh
shout out to Rhode Island Two Sold Out
shows there shout out to Boston Two Sold
Out shows there shout out to [ __ ] New
York homies and bosses the Army garbage
is strong my friend sweetheart
um but I do have one thing I never can
I've never seen you in a sweatshirt
before that's a lie I've recorded
episodes in this exact sweatshirt Toby
what do you think
uh Kimmy and a crew I have never seen it
before dude I've owned it looks like an
offensive coordinator in high school and
you're on the bench
hey why don't you go play with the other
girls huh that's where I do my best work
I can't be running the wishbone
um
yeah I've definitely I've had this shirt
for like two years I think at this point
okay
um
what do you got but I uh go ahead
they so I was down this is a rule we
talk about this a lot when we go out to
eat
it's the
the rule of eating
before everybody gets their food
what about like you know when the food
comes you the the the the proper thing
is to wait sure which I always ask of
course of course I'm big on them and
obviously sometimes you know extenuating
circumstances call for whatever you know
you get something hot cold what you know
what I mean you gotta leave whatever
something yeah if you got the [ __ ]
fajitas I'm not gonna let you sit there
and have them sizzling while I'm waiting
on my [ __ ] you know my crab cake or
something
um but I don't know what restaurants
serving fajitas and crab cakes but I
want to go
get me a gift card somebody David Olive
Gardens
Chichi Gardens
um ooh shout out to chichis did you [ __ ]
with chichis I don't know chichis was
doing it before anybody that was the
first time I ever witnessed chips and
salsa being put out on the table you
know I didn't [ __ ] with salsa for a long
really up until recently every
restaurant should do chips and salsa
what that's crazy it's so I mean so much
better than bread and butter is pretty
good but you can't do it anymore I know
it's great but why can't you do it
anymore I mean I can't because what do
you think chips are it's not that's not
like a hill it's not like [ __ ]
carrots then a Parker House roll in a
slab of butter I think it's a little bit
better for you I remember in the 90s we
legit thought yeah you're 400 pounds we
La jocked we we legit thought that chips
and salsa was was healthy oh yeah I
still kind of think that I'm also under
the belief of if the food if it's a nice
place it's healthier for me for some
reason that's how I think I think rich
people aren't you know what I mean I
think that's true it's it's less
processed it's more top quality yeah but
it's not I mean that's pasta is still
pasta it's not [ __ ] it's not like
more healthy Pasta it's not healthy but
it doesn't have the preservatives and
stuff like that I'm not worried about
that I mean we're the preservatives
aren't what is making us fat it makes
you unhealthy though
if you're gonna have something bad for
you it should be done to the best
possible way I know I know but what
you're not I'm saying I leave after
eating at a very nice restaurant I might
have had 14 000 calories and a half a
loaf of bread and dessert I walk out I
go oh well it wasn't McDonald's
I feel like I'm like still light on my
feet a little bit sure I got you but I
was I was down and I was away with my
family down here in Disney uh two weeks
ago whatever it was last week and uh we
went out to dinner there's a big group
of us 15 right got the whole kids the
whole nine yards and uh went out to a
nice restaurant and they started
dropping the food right it takes a long
time to serve 15 people I know should
all be done within a minute or two
though
me I don't know it was it was slow going
or whatever
um but some people at the table started
eating really so I made a comment as
like a fun you know the apps had already
happened yeah the apps that happened I
think this is me were the apps still on
the table scattered around could you
still be picking at the apps a little
bit I don't think so I think they
cleared it okay that's bad news because
if the apps are still on the table and
you got your little plate in front of
you and you can still you know take a
couple muscles this is what I heard a
little Calamine it's okay this was the
refute from a pretty classy person I
might add huh
um six or more you're allowed to eat you
don't have to wait for everybody six or
more people because that does jam up the
flow of food
you can't wait for 15 people to get food
that's a long time if you have a hot
steak that just got dropped that could
be three four minutes either way you
give it a couple of minutes you give it
two three minutes to see how the how the
service well also the service wasn't
good it was like this is going to be I
mean it was like 10 minutes for a drink
you know you were waiting a while it was
you weren't positive when things were
coming out okay but there's more so of
the rule of it Toby see if you can find
what is the standard because at some
point the the party hits a the party
hits a number where it's rude for the
people without food to make the person
wait and have their food get cold
there's a threshold there of like
yeah now it's it's rude that your your
food isn't as good as it could be not
many times 15 Irish Yaks I'll go on to
dinner potatoes same goddamn potato
side of Tater side of Tater side or
sanitator we'll all have the lemon
chicken
um but that made me that because there
has to be some sort of one of those
weird chivalrous rules of like in fine
dining or
dinner party etiquette there's a certain
threshold where it is then the right
thing to do I don't think there is I
think you're supposed to wait till
everybody has their meal before you
start eating I was 15 people that seems
crazy and that's what I'm saying if
there's like if it's a big the service
has got to be good the service is [ __ ]
up like you said what are you gonna do
you can't keep digging with the kids eat
they got the butter noodles how long did
it take I forget I mean I was probably
like four [ __ ] Manhattans deep at
that point but it was slow the whole
dinner was like three [ __ ] three out
it was a long a long [ __ ] process
okay
all right we got a ruling here from
tastingtable.com for big gatherings
weddings large businesses luncheons and
other such communal events uh the kind
of service takes a considerable amount
of time and coordination so unless you
want to choke down some cold filet you
should probably start eating as soon as
your table or seating area has been
served okay but that's for multiple
tables sure sure that's like in a way
this is sure but this is five four five
tables combined so I would say maybe
once your section once your error half
maybe or whatever yeah yes sir anyone in
your immediate vicinity sure anybody can
touch because everybody get steak hey
give me that
did everybody get steak uh I forget I
don't know I don't know probably maybe
that's a tough one I don't know but it
did
my interest because it was said real
quick six or more you don't have to wait
and I was like
I don't think that person made that up
you know what I mean so that was heard
somewhere so I was that's what I was
wondering if there's some sort of rule
of thumb and it does make sense to me a
little bit because I'm not one of those
guys of eat I don't care like you know
yeah also too if they're like oh your
filet is going to be right out you go
you know it's not because they know sure
oh it's just a few more minutes you're
going oh you're you're kicking this can
down the road so you don't Jam you're
getting out in front of this I think for
civility you take your time with those
first couple of minutes though you don't
woof it down like I mean you're not
[ __ ] you know grabbing the fries
before it hits the table
I am I also have eyes on something that
says if it's six or fewer at the table
you should wait to eat until everyone is
served okay so above that you're good to
go
six or more six or more there you go wow
huh okay
pretty crazy I'd love to know which one
of the Sullivans pulled that out of
their hat I know a couple of classy
people
not too shabby hey you know you guys
share dessert at the table uh I think so
I think we did we have a coffee
I know I probably I think I had another
Manhattan or two
I don't want to ride home
in a fight with Goofy yeah
what are you looking at you [ __ ]
cross-eyed [ __ ] slap his [ __ ] head
around you ain't a real dog
hi dog's better than you
start crying
um but we do have a family episode here
gang at 2-4 we got a couple of
humdingers over there guys so when you
sign up for the patreon we will answer
your garbage question on here it's the
best way to do it we get a lot of
submissions from a lot of different
places but the patreon gets the first
crack at it Daddy oh
um this one's from party talks baby yeah
get in line there's a VIP section I
don't know what to tell you
um this is from patio furniture who has
sent in a couple of humdingers in the
past
and I never thought of this I do it all
the time do you refer to microwaving as
nuking it yeah [ __ ] yeah nuke it two
three minutes
nuke in it yeah that was
state-of-the-art technology in the 1980s
what movie was that from where are they
getting uh [ __ ] it was the Christian
Bale was it was like in the 70s or
whatever the 70s Christian Bale yeah
they all it was not shot in this heavy
was set in the 70s it was like the
politics or the [ __ ] whatever
Christian Bale yeah you have like the
bad toupee oh American Hustle American
Hustle love it it was like FBI or
whatever yeah I love it yeah yeah she
they they gave what's her name yeah
Jennifer took that thing out of my house
I don't want the it sucks all the
nutrients out of the food it does too
man yeah but nuking it is trash we had
we've grown up I mean I guess it is a
new it's a new microwave uh that we had
a [ __ ] KitchenAid microwave man this
thing was tried and true I knew [ __ ]
we had the same one I'm [ __ ] probably
about 15 20. I knew every in and out of
that thing how many seconds to hold it
when to pop I [ __ ] man I knew this
thing so you're a race car the easy
minute button on that you just hit the
easy minute and it would start Crank
That about three four times come in pop
it in open it up it took my family about
seven years to figure out how to do
microwave popcorn without destroying it
I think it's like once the noises get
everything yeah one to two seconds
anything over two seconds you gotta pull
it it's always burned it then the smoke
alarm was going off she was screaming my
dad's like what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
and me and my brother are sitting there
eating burnt popcorn which I gotta be
honest with you here we go isn't that
bad sure is there any food you don't
like where you're like I don't eat that
I wouldn't eat that
um it seems like every time something
comes up good or bad you're like I gotta
tell you I don't mind eating shoelaces
shoelace Al Dente please
uh is there any food that I don't like
I'm not crazy about Pad Thai but I'll
eat it
sure okay I would say that's with the
nuts so the closest thing to you not
liking a food is not crazy about it yeah
I can't really think of anything that I
I mean I I'd eat liver but I've got to
be really hungry have liver and onions
uh-huh because my mom used to get she
used to tell us they were hamburgers
when I was little and she'd give us a
piece of her [ __ ] hamburger this
thing still bleeding [ __ ] brutal man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] bird dude if my mom
ever tried to give me liver as a kid I
would never trust her for the rest of my
life now get the [ __ ] out of here no no
goddamn way last secret you're getting a
mine he can't be trusted
um
yeah I don't think nothing
uni is is I I just haven't had it enough
the sea urchin we tried to have it one
time at a sushi place and fought back
it's a lot yeah it's it's it's it's a
it's an ocean punch we uh with Bert we
had some haggis we did okay okay okay
okay he ended up chotskying that up to
be all right he did that was good that
was very that was very
um uh corned beef it had a beef sausage
it had a hashy vibe to it but I don't
like sweet breads I can't [ __ ] with
sweet breads what do you mean do you
know what they are I mean not to the
fact that you wouldn't like them Toby
look up sweet breads this is that thing
like head cheese where it's all face
yeah I don't know if I could do that
either I never had tongue before cow's
tongue right over here
yeah I can't [ __ ] with anything with a
face
oh my God it's
yeah
I don't like eating stuff I have
I ain't got wings
laughs
yeah but if I got it in me kidneys liver
testicles yeah it's a tough one cheek
yeah lip well cheek
I think I've had beef cheek that's a
thing right I hear that's pretty good or
something yeah yeah the sweet breads is
tough I had it at Sammy's Romanian one
time I also had Schmaltz and I gotta be
honest I think I've said I've liked it
and that's the stuff in your foreskin
Schultz
schmeg
is that a real thing smegma that's like
the [ __ ] that clears around when you're
uncircumcised
I don't know I mean we can ask our
resident long hair if you're a dirty
piece of [ __ ] our resident thick cut
um schmoltz is like uh chicken oil
something I'm out yeah it's not great no
um yeah sweet bread stuff like that not
a bit not a big organ guy
mm-hmm but like I said I'll have liver
if I'm starving that's how I first
started eating sushi I was starving and
I had it sure I get you yeah break on
baby let's go yeah we're talking raycon
we're not talking about the other brand
yeah that charges your arm and a leg
doesn't matter gang whether you're
naughty or nice this year everyone on
your holiday list can use some premium
audio products from raycon yeah guys uh
whatever I I use them to take calls
they're fantastic they got wireless
earbuds headphone speakers that offer
premium sound a comfortable fit and let
me guess 54 hours of battery life at
half the price of the other premium
audio Brands as the big man mentioned
before they were nice enough the good
people of raycon were nice enough to
send them over to us man I'm doing work
I'm bebopping scat and working out I'm
lying I don't work out but when I think
about working out I would use rate
console there you go uh plus it makes uh
raycon makes it uh easy to shop for
every Tom Dick and Aunt hoodie in your
life with holiday gift guides you're
always going to get the best deal when
you use our special link buy recon.com
garbage uh the Recon website offers buy
now and pay letter options so if you're
a little bro as a joke do you still get
your raycons and for the next month
Recon will have a countdown to Christmas
with new pop-up flash deal for you to
take advantage of every single day order
between December 13th through December
20th and get free express shipping on
orders over 85 dollars when you use the
code holiday that's just two pairs of
every ear everyday earbuds for free
shipping
uh right now go to buy raycon.com
garbage 15 to get 15 off site wide with
code holiday plus free shipping that's
code holiday at biracon.com garbage 15
for 15 off your raycon purchase by
raycon.com garbage15 do it do it Adam n
e Hachi Machi I'm hard as a rock don't
act like you don't know what I'm talking
about gang we all love Adam and Eve here
and are you garbage yeah 50 off whatever
the website right now pick up something
a little something to spice things up
yeah a little something shoving your
poop scoot you know what I mean get it
going get get something put something
God damn holidays will you put your
something in something else talk to the
guys talk to the girls let's get it
cracking get kinky let's go we're only
here for a short time I know you bunch
of user freaks yeah which is fine put
the kids to bed lock the door and have
at it yeah you should see antuti's
nightstanding yikes this is a medieval's
dentist office uh go to adamandeve.com
select any one item and use code garbage
this is an exclusive offer so be sure to
support the show and use code garbage to
get 50 off and free shipping go to
adamandeve.com right now do it exclusive
offer fifty percent off and free
shipping with code garbage you want to
do that today go buy yourself something
nice for your guy nice for your gal for
yourself what are you doing go [ __ ] each
other yeah
um home run I have a question shout out
to nuke in it love it uh this one's from
Kristen H first time question here is it
garbage to have the spare tire rim on
the back of your car when there's no
Tire on it that's bad if you have the
area
for the tire you mean in the trunk no I
like on the outside
you know like all like on like SUVs on
like a Tracker yeah I mean that's what
comes to mind but a lot of like isuzu's
having a lot of jeeps have them
to have that thing exposed without the
tire is a tough look you know what I
mean you know what I always thought was
pretty trashy though they tried to make
it look real nice it's one of the
versions of a Cadillac that has this
half a tire in the back like it has the
spare tire in the back and you see the
wire wheels yeah I always thought that
was I always thought there was a dead
body in that truck I never understood
how it opened up yeah just kind of
maneuver you gotta like pull it down and
then open up the trunk
you ever have a car that had the gas
tank in the back of the car no like
under the license plate yeah man our
first car had that [ __ ] tough look
dude Jesus Christ
it was a model thing yeah what the [ __ ]
what year was this potting every chicken
and every pot no Model T in every
driveway yeah
um no we never had anything goofy like
that we had the we had the we had the
Woody van the Plymouth what is that a
devoyage that's on the side that was on
the side that we had that was like the
purple maroon
dark red whatever that was Woody van
with like super tinted out windows
looking back I don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on let me ask you this have
you ever been in a situation where your
dad had to change the tire on the side
of the road you ever been hemmed up like
that no but I remember one time that was
Panic City for the foleys dude one time
we were driving up the [ __ ] big
boulder Jack Frost it was like there was
like three cars going up it was like oh
like the dude like it was all the dads
took all the kids up skiing and snow but
there must have been 44 of us in a car
those Caravans were great I was in I was
in the back of a Jeep
like in the trunk of the Jeep the whole
ride me and like three other kids didn't
have seats we were just we used to get
around in the back of that thing [ __ ]
you're fighting the older kids in the
front it was like a [ __ ] it's like
trench warfare going over that going
over that seat and my dad was cranking
heaters obviously sure gentlemen couple
of more breads
and
the window it was a Jeep and the window
went down and then wouldn't go back up
[ __ ] God damn it man he drove
still cranking heaters too like dude it
was snowing and sleet and rain
and I remember the kid it was my
brother's body was right behind them
just getting [ __ ] his hair was wet
dude [ __ ] cigarette Ash and [ __ ]
fresh powder all over him and I remember
being like what are we going I was like
six I'm like what are we gonna do on our
way back because like this happened like
we were only we were like not even out
of the neighborhood yet and we still
[ __ ] cooked it all the way up and he
had a trash bag did he like taped oh my
God that's high school kids and would
like draw and then like if he had to
like change lanes or whatever he would
lower it so he could see out and he
would put it back it was bam yikes real
90 [ __ ] real 90 [ __ ] I was smoking
heaters
15 kids in a car no Map Quest no no
Google Maps no seat belts no problem
[ __ ] let's go yeah that's tough man
little sports radio maybe a [ __ ]
little 10-10 wins or whatever it is KYW
News Radio
they used to play that typewriter in the
background
this just didn't [ __ ] knocked me out
in the back seat
[Laughter]
um loved it
um all right this one's from the
Oklahoma comedian I never had a question
red is it garbage to wear surfing shirts
from Ross O'Neill Quicksilver Billabong
if you live in Oklahoma where there's no
ocean
um yeah are those cool no that's why
they're at Ross Billabong O'Neill
quick seal quicksilver's tough see what
happens with Brands I don't get it yeah
they used to I thought that was the good
[ __ ] well that's what happens it is to a
point right and then Hillbillies in
Oklahoma start wearing and then they
over produce at the point where it's not
cool it used to be like tough to get
your hands on a quick silver t-shirt a
cool Billabong t-shirt a [ __ ] O'Neill
t-shirt but I thought and they over
produced them
and then everybody has them and it's not
cool anymore but I thought if the brand
was true to the sport
it still would always remain in style
like Franklin
dudes stowaway you know they wear
Franklin gloves but that went uncool for
a long time Franklin was brutal yeah
that's what I'm saying he stunk yeah any
pair of miters or something
um hold on
here's if the if the brand is being sold
there it's a tuffle it's no longer cool
that's where I got all my G Unit shirts
it's like Carhartt will never be uncool
because it's quality clothing but is it
like a don't real Surfers wear O'Neill
stuff I would argue probably not
really yeah not for fashion just because
that's a good brand for surfing that's
what I'm saying I think it's I think I
don't know I mean I don't hang ten that
often but I think it's one in the same
like the second it starts being sold
there sure it loses its that's what
happened to DC that's what happened to
DC it's what happened to [ __ ] Zoo
York Ocean Pacific was big when I was a
kid it was big when you were a kid still
not big but yeah I remember I had a
couple of op shirts oh they were [ __ ]
I never get in your hand I'm at this my
neighbor had a billabong shirt and I was
like this guy is the coolest dude in the
world those OP commercials back in the
day man he wanted to live in California
toot sweet all the hot broads and
flavored sodas is that what you think
where the living's easy baby
as long as the eye can have you ever
tried to surf
yeah I actually surfed tonight that was
actually a big way you're talking about
no I'm too scared of sharks even as a
kid like you never like came across it
as a kid what do you think I was less
scared when I was a child I don't know
plus all the marine biologists try to
push it back guys I live here mom
she's trying to get me to [ __ ] this
dolphin because he was angry that day my
friend hang in my ear
ah no never I don't even like being
exposed on a boogie board we also
couldn't afford them exposed and I hated
the kids that got to bring those down on
the shore yeah we were body surfing or
nothing yeah my dad showed us how to
body serve once and that was it that was
that's it you're on your own kids
literally figure out the birds and the
bees I'll tell you what though when you
catch a wave down at the down there at
uh down in Jersey there's footage of me
[ __ ] shredding on the patreon it
feels like you're flying oh man you
can't even if if even if you cruise for
about two three seconds it feels like an
hour yeah you're really riding the [ __ ]
it's you and Mother Earth yeah [ __ ]
zoned in together but I didn't like to
be exposed on the Boogie Board because I
felt like I was a Sitting Duck I wanted
to be able to move in the water yeah in
case [ __ ] popped off of course but
naturally karate chop a shark right in
the [ __ ] nose yeah
um yeah no never surfed never surfed
never skied really
I sled I said on the beach I always say
if I was in Point Break I'd be the guy
that you the the big guy that sat on the
beach by the bonfire
kidnapped people
out of a troubled pet that's what he did
yeah
um I tried surfing once was never for I
was always too fat of a kid what are you
talking too young of an age I was a mean
Boogie boarder though yeah I could
really [ __ ]
it's pretty good I can really shred a
little bit what about you Johnny Utah
you ever [ __ ]
get out there in the big waves uh once
in Puerto Rico really got the worst
sunburn of my life Jesus your back's
torch
my entire [ __ ] body like a lobster
molting I would never do it just out of
respect for the art form of it I would
never want to be that guy out there
crossing up somebody's wave or something
like that I feel like you gotta start
that when you're young like there's a
spiritualness to that that I respect
okay you know I wouldn't want to be that
guy when I see that when we go to Hawaii
and I see the dudes in Hawaii man it's a
little different starting you up it's a
little different starting [ __ ]
Wildwood or [ __ ] you know finally on
the big island I always made fun of that
we had a couple of kids in my middle
school that surfed they're like where
are you surfing and they're like down
the shore down the shore get the [ __ ]
out of here this guy's in the bay you
don't surf at the Jersey Shore a lot of
people do they're not like legit waves
they're little baby waves
I should catch a hurricane coming in I
have cousins that when like do we it
would be bad weather daylight that's it
they go out yeah yeah yeah telling you
there's there's decent surfing in the
Jersey Shore I mean it's not [ __ ]
you're not making it the front of a
[ __ ] Riptide magazine or whatever but
you're not gonna be on the front of
[ __ ] Hang Ten week six wax weekly
yeah but I mean there's enough I think I
think of Surfing I think of uh the
[ __ ] North Shore in Oahu that's what
I think of why you just went there for
the first time three years ago how's
that what you think of Surfing as a kid
if I sat there and had coconut shrimp
watched it [ __ ] watch the real men
staring out the window of an Applebee's
watching them [ __ ] hang watch them
get towed in I always wanted to do that
I'd like to be the wave runner guy I
wouldn't mind that until ship pops off
what are you talking about run away dude
man those waves I'd rather be out I
don't know how anybody lives
when they [ __ ] huge wearing a 50-foot
wave they go underneath it they have CO2
in their life jackets and floats him to
the top is that true yes the Surfers
have that for the big waves yeah you
will probably just have to break your
Snickers bar in half
and the fish would come get you
unload some of the candy in my pocket
quick throw the lemon heads overboard
he's not athletic but he's buoyant
that's how they do it because I've seen
them
with uh with nothing on like they have
no shirt on and they just [ __ ] jump
off the board and just go underwater but
doesn't the wave take the board isn't
strapped in her leg
don't they get drug anyway I don't think
so I think it's all it's also I I listen
I'm by no means know what I'm talking
about but it's quick moving you know
what I mean so it's like
it depends on what part of the wave you
if the wave crashes on you it sucks you
to the bottom and it'll SL if there's a
reef or anything it'll press you into
the reef and then you get caught in a
like a like almost like an alligator
roll it spins you and spits you out the
other back yeah now I'm good
I'll try some of that pineapple right in
that pool you try it in the pool Sheltie
goes yeah that's pretty sweet Jersey
yeah but I heard a story about one of
those guys what got stuck in it well
there's like a there's a room I think
Bert was telling us or something like
that there's a room in the back that's
the motor like for that that sucks it's
like an empty room that sucks a bunch of
water in
and then pushes it out to make that
wave and some dude got sucked in to the
room
and so he's just in there waiting oh
while it's filling up going like all
right
like knowingly it's going to be
completely full and then he's just gotta
wait until it [ __ ] exits out or what
I forget I forget the story somebody I
think Bert was telling us they make it I
think so yeah he's like a famous guy
he's like a I don't know if he's like a
podcast or MMA guy or he's somebody like
relatively famous you know it's pretty
cool that guy I don't know his last name
Laird
I don't know big Surfer blonde headed
guy comic no he was in The Descendants
nothing oh he's cool as [ __ ] does a lot
of ice baths that guy Laird Hamilton
yeah dude that guy's [ __ ] awesome
it's all Nick dude a lot of Nick he
keeps it tight yeah
um surfing guys are all right sure tight
Bots
tight they keep it yeah that's why I
never I got a more boogie border bottom
I tried skimboarding more of a dunk tank
man myself shout out to it I skimboarded
for a summer maybe two [ __ ] damn near
broke my neck 22 times that thing goes
out from under here quick
man you think everything's all fun and
games until that slips out you trying to
look cool down the Jersey Shore probably
wearing a sweatsuit
your little blonde headed bowl cut I was
up with that by the way what do you mean
was that in style
yeah you're a little fat kid with a bowl
cut and you had like golden hair
for a minute yeah I think a lot of that
was sun and maybe I would dye it
I'm not proud
my mom would take me to buy women we'd
go to The Rite Aid and buy women's uh
hair dye and I would hair I would dye my
hair in like seventh eighth grade
sitting watching a [ __ ] rabbit ear TV
with your hair up in curlers you and
your mom dishing man that was always a
big thing going to school the next day
with a different color hair in seventh
grade that was like this could be real
bad this kid goes south real quick I had
a teacher who uh Eminem was huge what do
you want from me I had a teacher who
always had my respect but then really
got married I love that got my respect
when he did this he wore like the worst
toupee
for like 30 years like the worst toupee
okay everybody everybody knew it sure
and then one day after Christmas break
he just came back in mid-year just said
[ __ ] it you gotta do you gotta do that
over the summer and he no he came back
after winter break and he stood in front
of his class
outside as everybody was coming in and
going just to [ __ ] get out in front
get it all out of it now hey what's up
what's up let's do our couples walked up
and shook his hand it was like man
you're the [ __ ] man he was a great
teacher too Mr Crane history teacher
shout out to him
[ __ ] good dude I just remembered on
the Mateo episode you were asking about
the hair transplant yeah a lot of people
hit me up
and we were talking about I realized why
you could never do it why it's everybody
it's to everybody knows you've been
publicly thinned you can't then show up
like this guy no see that's the problem
I don't care if they know that's the I
don't I would say I would start every
episode off with I got plugs I don't
care if they know he'd do the plugs I do
the plugs I want to know where the line
would go like would it just go straight
across I wouldn't like your head though
some kid made some kid [ __ ] made one
and they gave me like a [ __ ]
it's me sitting here and it gave me a
[ __ ] tight one that looks pretty good
I had to zoom in myself
I say God damn keep it oh man you got me
what that Rogaine was working
uh no they would just like they would
like you know [ __ ] just fill I think
they would just fill it out a little bit
um my lucky you got a good head thanks
you have a good head if you were
completely bald you have a good head
thanks uh yeah I just wouldn't want it
to look bad and people behind my back
like that looks like [ __ ] that's what I
wouldn't want
I don't mind if people no I would tell
you I I'd [ __ ] put it on a goddamn
patreon let's make a couple of bucks pay
back you know people do on the double
League oh hey how you doing what the
[ __ ] I couldn't I couldn't deal with
that subreddits about my hair and stuff
Tippy's got fleas
oh hey how you doing I'd have to get
T-Bones high-pitched live voice oh it's
good
[Laughter]
he hit me with that the other day
walking I was like I was on fun oh God
this is gonna be tough
that's when I've been thinking about
what to get you for Christmas I've been
trying which by the way we've been
throwing around some crazy ideas by the
way
um how do you like Marrakech
uh I've been trying to what your
reaction would be opening up but I get
the oh I gotta
well now you know cause he lied last
year I know yeah
I was raised he gave away your [ __ ]
towel I want honesty in here I gave it
to you and you were upset
I told you your gift stunk I didn't say
I wouldn't be upset I just want honesty
okay let's talk about extra oh baby love
that extra I'm sitting on a tote right
now because I got a shitty old wallet
and now with Dexter we're talking about
slim Sleek smart wallets comes in almost
any variety to fit any style yeah they
were nice enough to send me one I got it
and you pull the trigger boom your cards
popped out real cool you look like a
real you look you can look like a guy
with a little bit of cash even when you
don't have any I'm getting rid of this
thing in my pocket I got baseball cards
in mind but you know whatever I still
look cool to check out couple sticks and
gum I still look cool as my debit cards
getting declined uh cyber week is their
biggest sale of the year with up to 35
off-site wide and with up to 45 off
selected cyber week bundles makes the
perfect gift for everyone on your list
in need of a refresh gals if you're out
there it's fantastic for for your Feller
guys if you're out there it's fantastic
for your fellow or your memo your Bebop
anybody whoever baby uh take advantage
of extras bundles with up to 40 off
their best selling items get 35 off
exter's wallets cyber week sale when you
use rlink at
shop.exter.com garbage use the code
garbage one more time shopexter.com
garbage use code garbage Link in the
description do it let's talk about
ladder baby l-a-d-d-e-r ladder yeah you
know we're talking about gang do
yourselves a favor don't leave your
family hanging in alerts when you kick
it over uh-huh all right a little
something for the kids take care of the
boys or we'll pick up one check in your
life how about that we're talking term
life here do yourself a favor get
yourself straightened out no doctors no
needles get up to three million dollars
of coverage look at that yeah uh just a
few questions about your health and
application I got 4.8 out of 5 stars on
trust pilot and they made Forbes best
Life Insurance Lesson 2021 what are we
[ __ ] doing here pretty good I got no
hidden fees you cancel any time to get a
full refund if you change your mind in
the first 30 days finally since life
insurance costs more as you age Now's
the Time to take it off your list when
are you gonna do when you're on your
deathbed I don't think so take care of
it now uh so go to latterlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage I'm gonna spell
it out for you one more time get you
going out get your little computer
yeah trying to figure out my gift yet
did I get your gift yeah I've asked
three more times what do you mean no you
sent it to me no did you buy my gift yet
no I haven't do you have any ideas yeah
I have an appointment tomorrow for it
hair transplant give me I got Mia here
get me a merkin
get the bushes and take that that would
be all time if you got Kippy a toupee
made out of your hair oh man would you
wear it
no out of my pubes
if I shortened curlies it's a bunch of
crumbs and stuff in there
um now I haven't made any purchases yet
all right
yeah I only got yours mine yeah nice
part of yours part of mine he's actually
looking at it today you were looking at
it today I put it on you put it on huh
that's weird sexy a little nighty
how are the girls of Victorious
this time of year
um all right let's get back into it uh
um this one let's see here this one's
just all right it's from Jake uh 10
shareholder are you garbage if you are
you garbage if you're in the first
picture that comes up when you Google
your local dive bar I never worked there
and I don't own the place
drooling or like being a creep in the
corner that was bad getting caught in
pictures back in the day before cell
phones when it was like digital cameras
that was I was in college so girls were
running around with those little silver
whatever digital camera they were huge
every girl group had one they go out and
they take 10 000 pictures they went so
quick though oh yeah I mean the
technology to the phone call I mean
there was already camera phones but they
sucked it was like I remember the
Christmas where they were a big thing my
mom got one digital camera digital cam
my stepdad used to have that big one do
you remember that it was like you would
hold it had like two handles on the side
oh man it was [ __ ] he would bring
that out at Christmas and people like
dude kick rocks with that wait an email
how are we gonna get these things it was
like before emailing [ __ ] yeah man but
then the next Christmas day we're
[ __ ] gone but there was like two
years in college where those were half
freshman year they were real hot
and man they would go these girls would
go out we'd all go out they would take
like 50 to 100 pictures at night right
and then uh so it would take like a
hundred [ __ ] pictures at night and
they wouldn't be we didn't know like
framing and whatever so it was just like
you would just end up in the back of a
bunch of pictures sure [ __ ] or
beady-eyed and sweaty hence the
photobomb oh the photobomb started to
emerge yeah but these were unintentioned
you were just like I would be in the
back leaning on the wall real creepy in
a basement or something like that
[ __ ] end up they tagging what are you
doing tagging me doing a shot of blue
cheese
and that was a fuzzy naval guy back in
those days her red eyes and a bowl full
of hard shells
they were tough walks they would really
catch you now it's tighter frames it's
easier I always thought
um whenever you worked at a restaurant
if they were like redoing the website or
there would always be a photo shoot at
some point if they were freshening up
the website or if they were doing
yeah yeah I was never asked to be in
those oh what are you talking about yeah
doing blow in the back getting after it
um all right this one's from Bruce uh is
it garbage to bring your own Tupperware
to a dinner in case that you want to
bring stuff home yes yes I mean this
whole thing we had to do at the show
you're saying it is garbage well of
course okay I don't know the girl that
went to the wedding with the Tupperware
yeah I mean she was a cheetah wouldn't
even do it yet she was planning on
taking it to the wedding next week
or whatever it was yeah that's crazy
that's nuts to me I mean like
yeah wrap it up put it in tin foil what
do something but to be like I got my
Tupperware all and then do you bring it
into the house or do you leave it in the
car I've heard it it's crazy if you're
like sitting down it's on the table it's
an empty Tupperware yeah that's like
that's psychopathy that's first degree
dirt bag it's premeditated yeah okay
there's men's rail in line with that
um capital punishment for that uh I know
of ladies will go to like an
all-you-can-eat seafood boil or you know
whatever and they'll line their purse
with plastic or tinfoil and they'll
throw like a couple of lobsters and some
crab legs in there Kim Congdon talked
about that they would go through her mom
there we go have like Lobster at the
house yeah it's like
it's an embarrassment thing for me it's
a shame thing of like if they were like
sure
is that a lobster in your backpack like
that would be you know are you is that
is there lobsters in your hoodie I would
have to move you know what I mean like I
wouldn't be able to I wouldn't be able
to sleep for like a week if that
happened if you take leftovers I'd spend
money or I'll just have [ __ ] hot dogs
you take leftovers that's fine but you
can't roll in with a [ __ ] empty
Tupperware
man that's a bad luck yeah although I'll
say this when you go to like a family
party if they have the Tupperware there
and they start breaking out my cousin
had done Thanksgiving they had a bunch
of fresh Tupperware and they packed up
like they're cheap not cheap but not
like yeah it's a little glass not like
heavy no no yeah yeah the ones you use a
couple of times they're still floating
around like the heavy heavy drones
probably not it's probably replaced by
like the more disposable cheaper no we
got a couple heavy bike ones at the
house yeah I'm gonna say new wise are
they really banging with those it's
probably all glass and stuff at this
point sure glasses yeah Ikea does the
glass ones real nice real classy you
want that back
remember that I gotta go pick up a
cookie sheet from uh dolores's house
yeah send that thing back Patty always
kept a couple of them
yeah my Aunt Patty gave me we always
ended up with like you know two or three
serving dishes that probably weren't
really ours sure she's got Sticky
Fingers that one she takes everything it
ain't folded down
uh I felt like it moved he felt he felt
Rich my aunt gave us this was during the
pandemic I think it was
Chris it was Easter I guess we went over
to give us like Easter food is this when
you were like you're wearing a lot of
even like be anywhere near each other
she like left it outside we got it and
took it and like she like asked me I
threw the Tupperware out it was like
Applebee's to-go containers it wasn't
like Tupperware branded it was like
reused you know but like heavier to go
stuff sure but from a third party sure
not you know these were it wasn't
baldness set okay I threw them out and I
remember being like I'm not [ __ ]
washing these in returns they say
[ __ ] you know chichis on them or
whatever gotta call them you did I think
my mom was like you better give those
back damn Patty or something what what's
digging through the trash I don't know I
don't need to wrath the [ __ ] P Mayo
after me fighting a raccoon to get the
lid back yeah it was tough that just
made me really hungry for Easter food
okay I like a nice Easter meal the
pineapple upside down cake
uh also like some kind of pineapple Mash
or something like that
I don't know
a little bit of egg salad sure good
stuff
what you don't like Easter I didn't know
there was food associated with yeah
dumbass what do you mean Easter Easter
Sunday dinner ham pineapple upside down
cake scalloped potatoes Patty Maker
cheese potatoes a little coleslaw a
couple deviled eggs you probably start
off with a grass they put the candy in
I hated that [ __ ]
stick to my peeps
was it sound
if I can lose it
yeah man that's pretty trashy bringing
Tupperware
and hopes
I don't
yeah it's not for me hey I got I got a
lot of I just have a lot of feelings
about it it's just in every set of the
way it's not good I have a family member
who shall remain nameless to protect the
innocent five
um
will bring stuff there
for you know if Patty's making cutlets
let's say Patty's making collets let's
say that and she's bringing the cutlets
over there
let's say Patty made I don't know 60
cutlets there's gonna be a few people
there all right
this said gentlemen will take some of
the cutlets and already pack them up and
put them in the beforehand beforehand
that's crazy so they can have them for
the week I grab your hand and go what
what are you doing there dude
is that but is that also done like hey
I'm making 20 for Glenn
I'm making 10 cutlets for you put
everything I'm just asking I don't know
the deal they have you can't it doesn't
matter they have Patty's making me ten
cutlets I go over I want to do this
there we go also hey I don't blame him
if you're floating around the kitchen
all right you're [ __ ] eating
everything that has breadcrumbs on it no
it's it's that person's house it's got a
master lock on the top
it's got a handcuffed to his hand
give me the codes you're chasing them
out to the car with a bandsaw to take
his hands off
shooting with a silencer wait so Patty
you guys take the cutlets to the
gentleman's house right let's say this
the gentleman's having a little a little
thing a lot of times that's uh a lot of
that's gonna get subcontracted out
Patty's gonna make the Cutlass sell but
out my sister-in-law's gonna take
estimates on those jobs or are they no
big contract my sister-in-law is going
to make a lasagna bring that over
um but before anything's even served
they're already stashing reserves away
for the week this did this gentleman
what I'm saying is that a convo
made by upper management no no
and the way I see it is you make sure
you got everything forever you see it
you want more cutlets everybody gets it
here there's no [ __ ] everybody
understands big man like Cutters okay
Patty's cuddies man they're big
they're big [ __ ] drives me crazy yeah
when you start rationing things away
before the guests have even had a chance
to get a second or third help
it's ridiculous I mean
plus they're push out I hate when they
wrap it up too quickly it's like whoa
take it easy where are we going is it do
you think this this sentiment is shared
with other people or is this an H I
think this this seems to be a very H
Foley thing I'm not saying you're wrong
in the sense of like hey give you know
it would be me but this just seems like
a fat guy who wants to eat cutlets I
mean if I'm calling a spade a Spain the
only other gentleman that was privy to
would be my father him and I went on the
way home in the car but hey
yeah okay [ __ ] two tree cutlets all
secrets die with him too you know what I
mean
uh
um all right this one's from Pat haven't
had a question yet is it garbage is
someone in your family owns a pet monkey
for context my aunt had a small Tamarind
when we were growing up and it was wild
no cage no pen just loose in their small
house in central Pennsylvania one time
they brought it to my parents house in
New Jersey where it dove into the big
bowl of peas at Thanksgiving dinner
which very much upset ma who didn't want
a monkey in her house in the first
dude
it would regularly do stuff like over
the TV stand and throw DVDs all over the
living room
eventually bit my little cousin's finger
so they had to send it back to the
Jungle
dude bringing over a monkey to someone's
house is just crazy I'm having a
monkey's nuts thinking someone else
wants a monkey in their house is crazy
send it back to the Jungle means that
got hit with a [ __ ] commemorative
mini baseball bat to the back of the
head can toss in a dumpster behind
Marshalls that God that got dropped off
in a field somewhere that thing still
wreaking havoc swinging from the monkey
bars at the playground if I was in
Pennsylvania and came across a monkey in
the woods
I'm opening opening up with all guns oh
that's [ __ ] nuts man dude opening the
TV stand and throwing DVDs all over the
living rooms those things are a little
[ __ ] yeah they're shitty let me see
what let me see what one of those things
look like hammerind yeah I think that's
like the main uh like one of the main
ones that you always see
like the outbreak monkey uh
uh I think so yeah I wouldn't be able to
handle that
oh no never mind let me see it this
thing's oh this thing is scary [ __ ] you
dude it looks like a sunset oh man what
the [ __ ] dude
are you kidding me
oh dude I get him when he's sleeping
there's a little diaper on and [ __ ]
take him out I'm an animal lover
but that thing looks possessed he starts
throwing it around my bad boys I ain't
be scratching him [ __ ] up dinner oh
dude diving into a bowl of bees dude
let's think [ __ ] everywhere they picked
their nose scratching their balls plus
they're always jerking off it's like
hanging out with you
this guy seems all right
I like I like little baby monkeys of
course but I'd want a little baby
chimpanzee that's what you want one of
them they know what's going on they're
cool they know to go for the throat and
the gonads they don't [ __ ] around when
they lose it they lose it you're nuts
just let's play smoke and they ride
skateboards oh also you want to know uh
I had I was like I said I was down in uh
Disney with uh my family this is how
trashy I realize my whole family is just
like how blue collar
level of level of just trash we are
we're in I don't [ __ ] know one of the
there's like an aquarium type thing and
like you're deep down in it there's like
a system of like hallways and tube and
you're like it's all around you the
Sharks and [ __ ] Dolphins the whole night
and there's like three scuba divers down
there fixing something really and I mean
you not one of us looked at an animal
once we saw the guy it was just oh yeah
a group of us just watching dudes work
and we're like What do you think they're
done here you guys got a welder I see I
see the socket wrench over there and we
just sat there for about 45 minutes
watching three guys work yeah I like
that oh mesmerized [ __ ] the grouper I
know watching dudes get [ __ ] done
mesmerized by guys working underwater
dude I'm a stupid construction guys like
look at how he's got oh there's another
one in the back holy [ __ ] I even see the
third one that's eating his lunch look
at him guys guys on a sick break buddy
put your mask on
I don't know that stuff fascinates me of
course because we're trash underwater I
don't think the [ __ ] you know the the
Rockefellers would be you know they'd be
looking more at the shark or whatever at
the rainbow fish yeah now dude
underwater welder man you got my
attention I catch one of those on
[ __ ] the History Channel give me 12
steps ooh that's all right that's not
bad we were [ __ ] mesmerized we had a
face on the glass just looking
[ __ ] breathing and [ __ ] like oh look
I dropped the ranch out of [ __ ]
what do you think an underwater welder
gets paid an hour a [ __ ] ton a [ __ ]
it's dangerous probably 250 an hour 31
bucks get the [ __ ] out of here it's not
worth it guys gotta join a union yeah no
that's not right those guys those guys
on like the oil rigs in the in the ocean
they they're they're well paid I mean 31
is relatively well paid it's probably 70
000 a year
sure
you gotta go down there and [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] in the dark where you can't
see it that stuff's dangerous
pressurized suits the sharks catch a
starfish on your face that's Horrors
looking at you suck your eyeballs yeah
suck your eyeballs out of your head
um all right this one's from Harris are
you garbage if your mom takes a grocery
cart off the street to move groceries
from the garage to the house
so my understanding of that is they have
a they have a shopping cart let's
establish this
if there is a shopping cart anywhere on
your property
you're [ __ ] trash 100 there's no way
around if it's flipped upside down and
you're grilling on some High Grass
you're even more trash yeah
um my I think I told you my in-laws have
the pan basket that they took from the
supermarket that's not bad which is all
right functionality wise ain't bad yeah
they use it for like produce or
something I forget why they go to like
the farmer's market and they just carry
that with them throw in your [ __ ]
your sweet potatoes I never thought
about stealing one of those yeah it's
pretty all right it's heavy duty till
good one not one of those [ __ ] Rinky
Dinks but the little metal handles and a
black plastic sure this thing's this
thing's all right huh you ever use the
short cart
wow I'd be wearing I'd rather wear a
dress in public than wear than [ __ ]
push that thing around it takes a lot
for me to use a hand basket a heavy bike
with that the big boy oh yeah one it's a
shot to my manhood if I can't and it's
just flawed logic but if I can't carry
under thing everything in my arms I feel
like I failed you know I I I I I've
passed that I make it easy on myself I
get the I get the little handbag you
don't need the hand basket you do the
drag one no out of my head
you're only getting beans if you carry
one of those things uh I do everything
on I'll do stuff under my arms I stack
it I do anything to not have to get a
card for real these New York City things
are [ __ ] tight I always go for a
basket I'll throw a basket if I know
what I'm getting when I'm going in it's
a lot of things I'll do a basket
well we're rarely also we're rarely
doing an order
have you ever used one of those baskets
for your laundry that you see people in
New York rolling around then but the two
big wheels on them
the granny baskets oh no yeah whatever
you know
now push in your laundry down the street
like Mrs ragicino
yeah no I never I don't [ __ ] with that
I don't uh
uh yeah I try to keep it [ __ ] easy I
try to be in and out I don't try to like
pushing stuff the car the whole nine I I
use the [ __ ] self-checkout keep my
head down and keep it moving I like the
regular checkout
I don't mind it either man but listen I
want them to bag it up too I've said it
before no one cares less about you than
a cashier in a New York City Supermarket
sure you might as well be knocking on
their bedroom door waking them up to see
if you can check they can check you out
sure they don't they just they're slow
that self-checkout though they get
[ __ ] jammed up wait for attending if
something doesn't go through and that's
a guy that's the guy that wants to help
you the least you're clearly not you
know you're clearly not capable enough
to do self-checkout and sometimes the
thing doesn't register when you put it
in the bag area they start yelling at
you put it in the bagging area put it in
the bag it isn't the [ __ ] bagging
area I got well this I mean this is
you know I get I get so mad it drives me
nuts the one machine
it goes you you know how you have to buy
your bags now right which is [ __ ] I
don't mind it uh you buy your bag the
reusable ones yeah those are rock with
yeah you turn it into a trash bag you
throw a pair of shoes in there when
you're traveling whatever you know what
I mean Target's got a lot of balls
charging for those though those I steal
really what again [ __ ] I don't like
stealing because I don't steal either
but I'm not you just said you steal them
that's the that's H Foley hey I steal
them I don't steal when they ask you how
many bags did you use I hit zero
even if I take it back please steal them
I guess so you hear that Target I got
your guy right here red team go
Abracadabra
I mean they got a lot of [ __ ] balls
my friend wrote that line local
supermarket okay
um
Abracadabra abracadabra
you're a thief just admit
probably still probably stealing my
wallet right now
um
it asks me
it a it asks me
when you enter how many bags did you use
I'll do one and then it says do you want
to skip bagging this item and I'm like
it's the bag how do you bag a bag how do
we you know what I mean are you Seinfeld
it is what's the deal well I mean you
got to do it you go I gotta that's why
you don't put nothing and just grifted
I'm not gonna I I go to a local guy he
lives in a neighborhood I can't stop it
of course you can yeah Target [ __ ] up
Associated supermarkets on the other
hand I fleece them every chance I get
they're not gonna miss it I keep asking
for samples of cheese and I just put
them in tupperware and I roll out pound
and a half slice thing a little thinner
man nothing like getting that Slice on
this when was the last time you did that
I feel that's not a thing I you know I
don't see anybody in New York doing it
no yeah maybe a kid will get the slice
or whatever my Trade Fair yeah I know
the the guy the guy will uh break off a
little something
um some get your head on straight before
you get home yeah within the last six
months for sure oh I also slice a turkey
I also don't do the fresh sliced
they slice it every day and then put
like packs out of there oh yeah just
grab that I gotta wait that'll do my
Roll-Ups at home watching the carbs sure
and then have pizza at night
um all right this one's from remix uh
ten dollar homie never had one red is it
garbage to charge your buddy to listen
to patreon episodes come on I gotta wet
my beat too
couldn't respect it more that's awesome
hey I'm in as long as I want to use pain
I don't care
game the system you're if you're making
money I'm in you got a third party yeah
that's all it's like StubHub out here
those are hard feelings for six bucks
four hours off I can't [ __ ] hate it
that's all right uh this one's trying to
happen to the homies it's on some ten
dollar Bozo here is a garbage to take a
full-sized area rug to the beach instead
of towels to sit on they're thicker and
more stable so they actually make it
easier to have picnics on but it's still
a living room rug at the beach
that seems
those things aren't light either no
that's a hump they're like I mean so
you're rolling to the beach with like
two dudes
on their shoulders with like a sheet or
something I've seen that that's not that
bad they do the fitted sheet and then
you can like
oh yeah put stuff in the corner like
sand in the corners and it creates like
a little yeah that whole Situation's a
[ __ ] nightmare I like it what I would
like is five of those things and then a
[ __ ] tent in the middle like some
kind of [ __ ] Arab Chic back in the
day uh-huh you know what I mean you do
the tents yeah the fam does the you know
the big when we go to the beach with
like when I meet like my cousin [ __ ] at
the beach they do the because yeah pain
in the ass getting that thing [ __ ]
rolled up
dude
no way you're gonna have like a [ __ ]
truck with a rack on it to move that
thing that ain't fitting in like a
Corolla or something
you gotta move to go to the beach yeah
that's pretty trashy man
um all right this one's from Jessie uh
ever ride your bicycle on a highway at
night
that's two strikes the highway on a bike
on a highway is rough yeah
it's tough to be riding a bike or
walking anywhere where people haven't
walked in a while it's like if you're
stepping over a hubcap it's a bad look
that's like if you hit him you're kind
of doing him a favor a little bit
okay you're right to the [ __ ]
drainage ditch
you're better off man yeah to the side
of the Cross and keep it moving yeah
that's a that's an adult man on a kid's
bike no 100 Dude any adult man on a
kid's bike stay the [ __ ] away from him
he's a killer there's this guy that runs
he's got nothing to lose there's this
guy who's been riding around uh this
neighborhood Somerton it's at the you
know very top of the Northeast right
before the suburbs it's called Somerton
and this guy he's like the size of you
with red hair
and
[ __ ] he's been riding around
somewhere to he's your age at this point
he's been riding around on a BMX bike
it's crazy to see a 400 pound guy with
[ __ ] huge red hair riding a BMX bike
for 20 years it's wild
yeah he's still like hopping up curves
and stuff he keeps it moving he's always
going somewhere he's never just cruising
the guy's on a mission man
you know it's a really tough look BMX
bike with the handlebars folded forward
oh that's that's no good
scary yeah you put him for it a little
bit I'm talking lay flat how do you even
Ride Like That riding dirty baby what do
you mean so normally normally
I we used to put them a little bit
forward
like a little bit it would be like that
yeah yeah
you're talking like down by the tire not
a lot of crackheads and Bluebell huh
yeah that means I got a bad bike they
got wrenches to fix it they're busy
smoking crack oh yeah I bet those things
give out on me though huh
we used to we used to when we were like
into biking like BMX or whatever for a
year we would do uh we would cut the
handlebars so they were smaller so you
had like more like uh ferocity or
whatever you got more you got cooking
quicker really yeah yeah it's weird
uh-huh how would you cut them with like
a hacksaw the pipe cutter huh like you
know it's like the little thing you
screw it on and you sure zip it around
things are all right yeah it's not bad
yeah we were very unsupervised for a
large chunk of our
uh childhood like
crazy welding material being used
yeah acetylene do torches drills we
would was one time I remember building a
half plate we never finished it we were
building a half-life in my buddy's
backyard they were redoing his basement
and we just went in and took all the
wood
and she's like yeah we can do it I'm
like I'm like if my dad was here we my
dad your dad's gonna be pissed when he
comes home but I'm like hey I'm
following your rules here you know what
I mean I wanna I wanna [ __ ] drop in
let's go we got our hands on a nail gun
one time they were doing construction at
uh they were putting a addition on uh
one of my cousin's house
man really got him yeah it was right
around the time that [ __ ] uh Lethal
Weapon
there's we used to [ __ ] we were
petrified of this thing yeah put two of
those into a tree
man playing on a construction site as a
kid ain't nothing better good times to
your phone in the basement
um all right let's see we gotta do one
more and then we gotta go there uh this
one's pretty cuckoo bananas is from Sam
first time long time is it garbage to
use your workers comp settlement to pay
for your wife's new boob job
that that's leveling up on [ __ ] two
three different levels right there if
you think about it shout out yeah I mean
let's talk about everybody wins that's
what I'm saying dude yeah I don't see a
downside to that
[Laughter]
we gotta wrap it up gang we love you to
death we love you baby shout out to the
[ __ ] Army garbage I'm passing we got
the plaque baby look at that gang we
[ __ ] love you uh-huh Gramercy theater
we added a third Show come out and see
us if you're in the New York City area
New Year's Day we're going to be doing
the live stream I feel like L.A read
yeah it's good stuff Platinum plaques
baby it's gonna be a good time a lot of
fun things coming up check out the show
come and see us check out the live
stream yeah we love you baby we love you
and we'll see you next week peace